pour le groupe est républicain la parole
de tamasu gérard noël merci madame la
présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre
ces dernières semaines ont été chargés
en matière de politique étrangère
tellement chargé que nous avons assisté
à de nombreux revirements les plus
marquants et le nouveau rapprochement
avec la russie
le président de la république que votre
gouvernement refusait en effet toute
coopération avec ce pays sur le plan
international
votre intransigeance a atteint 6
notamment coûté au pays plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros rien que
dans la sphère des frégates mistral la
donne a changé
dorénavant touchés par le terrorisme nos
deux pays ouvre un nouveau chapitre dans
leurs relations bilatérales
la guerre déclarée contre l'ennemi
absolu l'état islamique nous oblige à
revoir la politique internationale
pourtant monsieur le premier ministre
cela fait des mois que nous vous
demandons d'apaiser les relations avec
la russie
aujourd'hui le président de la
république l'a dit nous sommes en guerre
et voulu vous le dites aussi à ne peut
être gagnée sans une grande coalition
regroupant des pays occidentaux la
russie l'iran et des pays du
moyen-orient
votre politique menée jusque là n'a pas
eu seulement des conséquences au niveau
de la vente des mistral mais aussi sur
nos agriculteurs la russie en réponse à
votre politique intransigeante à imposer
un embargo sur nos produits agricoles
nos agriculteurs plus que tous les
autres régulateurs européens en
souffrent ils ont été touchés de plein
fouet par ces décisions
la semaine dernière notre collègue axel
poniatowski vous avez déjà posé cette
question à laquelle vous n'avez pas
répondu
maintenant que nos deux pays se
rapproche enfin allez vous être cohérent
en levant les sanctions économiques à
l'égard de la russie et permettre ainsi
à nos agriculteurs de restaurer leurs
échanges commerciaux avec ce pays
merci la parole et au secrétaire d'état
chargé du commerce extérieur
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
gérard manuel il faut suivre de près la
politique étrangère de la france et en
le faisant
en faisant donc une analyse honnête on
constate que nous échangeons avec la
syrie depuis de longs mois et depuis de
longues années
c'est vrai sur le nucléaire iranien nous
avons négocié en permanence avec la
russie c'est vrai sur la question de la
crise
l'ukrainienne où le président de la
république avec d'autres a été à
l'initiative du format normandie qui
inclut précisément la russie dans les
négociations c'est vrai pour la syrie
puisque nous sommes depuis longtemps
demandeurs d'une coordination de notre
action militaire contre des chefs à
condition que ce soit bien des choses
qui soient effectivement visé ce n'est
pas le cas encore jusqu'à maintenant
dans la politique de la russie
nous pensons que des événements récents
peuvent conduire un changement amoussou
mais vous le voyez monsieur le député
les sanctions contrairement à ce que
vous laissez entendre ne tombe pas du
ciel
elles s'inscrivent dans un contexte
politique très particulier le processus
de minsk et la coordination avec nos 27
partenaires de l'union européenne sur ce
sujet et ce n'est que dans ce cadre là
que par ailleurs les sanctions pourront
être levés
nous savons par ailleurs parfaitement
qu'elles ont un impact très fort sur
certains secteurs industriels et sur
certains secteurs agricole et sur des
régions en matière agricole même dans
les temps les plus favorables
la russie représente un peu plus de 1 %
de nos exportations
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'elles
n'ont pas un prix fort pour ceux qui
sont concernés et avec stéphane le foll
nous menons une diplomatie des terroirs
pour ouvrir de nouveaux marchés
obtenir des agréments et trouver un
suite d'autres débouchés
nous travaillons ainsi la diplomatie des
terroirs la diplomatie économique et la
diplomatie politique de la france vont
ensemble c'est la seule manière dont un
membre permanent du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu peut travailler sur ce sujet
pour le